en
[Musique]
salle et que c'est lourd
j'ai chipait les boules de pétanque de
casimir
au ac vous je vous en parle vous
demandez pourquoi j'ai pris les boules
de pétanque de casimir et bien c'est
parce que ce balourd doit faire une
partie de pétanque avec monsieur du stop
et le facteur et qu'il ne m'a pas invité
mois il trouve que j'ai les biceps trop
maigre pour lancer les boules moi qui ai
mis monsieur martin deux voies chaos
incroyable non
attention le voile prenons un air
détaché vite vite vite mes boules de
pétanque je vais leur flanquer une
raclée 15 à 0
voyons voir
alors j'étais persuadé de les avants
ranger là
je ne comprends plus les lieux n'a pas
vu mes boules de pétanque ont tu ces
casimir le rangement et toi ça fait deux
on se doit les avoir mises à leur sache
petit renard que je ne suis peut-être
pas un modèle d'ordre mais en ce qui
concerne ma collection de bol de
gloubiboulga et mes boules de pétanque
je les range toujours dans ce placard
mais les boules de pétanque n'y sont pas
elles sont donc ailleurs bah oui
évidemment s'ils ne sont pas la leçon
ailleurs
quand je les vois oui oui là-bas sont
les coussins merci tu étais un bras
petit renard
mais non triple buse elles ne sont pas
là on
regarde sous la table la table mais
elles n'y sont pas non plus
je suis ton poisson rouge les uns
peut-être avaler enfin tu te moques de
moi qui sait bien qu'il est en voyage
qui marche je vais descendre
de 4 à 7 ans des milliers de fois je me
souviens maintenant je me souviens
elles sont on rouler tout seul dehors la
maison ont été vus très bien merci je
cours après
elle n'a pas fini de courir
téléspectateurs et voilà tout est prêt
salif en soi qu'est ce que tu fabriques
bien je suis en train de préparer un jeu
goûter qu'est ce que c'est qu'un jeu
goûter et c'est très facile je vais
distribuer tous ces fruits aux enfants
mais avant avant ils devront me dire
ceux qui ont des pépins et ceux qui ont
dénoué c'est une idée formidable
dis moi ce que je peux faire mon père
avec toi certainement je les
ai chez vous vous essayez de répondre
pépin boyau ceci à ça
ce sont des réserves c'est un fruit
happé par
une mandarine un fruit à péta tu te
forte une pomme fruits à pépins
formidable ceci un avocat alors c'est un
fait avec un gros noyau
on a déjà vu une orange à fruits à
pépins j'y
réponds que moussa fruits à pépins tueur
c'est des choses un joli roule à cette
fois
une date à fruits à noyaux regarde ce
très beau fruit c'est une mode saas est
délicieux et c'est un fruit avec un gros
noyau
à il a deux pieds décollés une brune un
fruits à noyaux
une cerise à fruits à noyaux qui traduit
sa vente du comme mouches
à fruits happé par le citron je pense
que les autres faute aussi fort que doit
tout à l'heure une olive à fruits à
noyaux
et voilà le dernier c'est un pruneau en
fait c'est une prune sécher une couette
c'est un fruits à noyaux de la motion
c en récompense oui mais les enfants ne
sont pas encore arrivés dit allons les
chercher d'abord tu raison de
dix minutes de retard casimir à 10
minutes quand tu as d'autant plus
étonnamment chers amis que d'habitude
qu'à tenir à une demi heure d'avancé
pour des matchs de pétanque et riri
minutes enfin pour sûr je n'en reviens
pas dix minutes et une demi minute des
idées tourner olala
11 minutes de retard mais ce que du seul
homme c'est impensable
il a dû souvent rives un accident
j'arrive excusez moi pour ce retard
laissez-moi entendement souffler un
grand malheur est arrivé à
hambourg sur cette catastrophe mais
boules de pétanque ont disparu
c'est très fâché parce que de ce fait
j'ai attendu pour rien moi je savais que
vous seriez déçu alors j'ai apporté
cette corbeille de fruits à
le moose des oranges des pêches des
citrons tient des pommes oui des pommes
je remercie quelques temps j'ai déjà
pris des desserts sinon c'était avec
plaisir ah ben non moi je ferais
volontiers un petit jus avec tout ça ça
remonte le moral a tenté de minimiser
ses fruits ne sont pas destinés à être
mangés tout de suite ils vont remplacer
nos boules de pétanque
quelle idée formidable montrait bien moi
je prends les zorros à
moi je prends les pommes cette
institution alors et moi ça me rendrait
les peuples ministre
et ce grâce de muscat fera le cochonnet
très bien après allons-y attention à
bien voilà a très bien je commence mon
but
c'est un peu loin
je vous signale que oui le gagnant aura
le droit de manger toutes les boules en
cours ou les avoir épluché les dames à
paris tu casimir
ah c'est pas mal à moi
voyons
le pousser votre barbe
à à à 1 contre à droite
les enfants venez vite venez vite nous
allons faire un jeu sur les fruits et
ensuite nous les mangemorts vous
installer dans l'herbe voilà comme ça
maintenant julie tu prends la corbeille
de fruits s'il te plaît tu es où la
corbeille de fruits elle a disparu
je suis navré je vous ai fait venir pour
rien brosse à véria va en faire un autre
jeux à quoi pourrait toujours y gilles
pison vol pigeon vole alors
j'ai battu le facteur est masterpiece
nab 15 à 0
mais à nous vous cherchiez sans doute
votre corbeille de fruits et oui casino
de chaillot la voilà j'ai entendu parler
du jeu que préparait françois mais je ne
trouvais pas ça très intéressant alors
vous allez changer un peu
les émirs ou sur les fruits et les
foyers bien que je les ai mangés voilà
et nous allons faire un jeu sur les
pépins et noyau mois ci des noyaux d'un
de prune un des noyaux de dattes des
noyaux de cerises à des noyaux d'olives
a ici des pépins de pamplemousse à des
pépins de citron des pépins de raisin et
un noyau d'avocats
ou voilà
résumé
[Musique]